walk him to this video this is some bit
out of the ordinary this video but i got
a request to do a video about the story
that i brought to the channels attention
about three months ago and it was not
only the the story but also what
happened afterwards um and i was asked
to do an update about what what happened
after that and yeah i'm glad to do that
i actually intended to do this anyway
but i had hoped for some more news to
pass on but ok let's do this now this is
about um this some appeal that was this
asked um this request for help that was
some put forward by Georgian
international master media salumi
because a little daughter four month old
um was suffering from a severe heart
diseases also hope this isn't working
i'm really doing captures from websites
and this is from the original article on
chess.com see a small picture of her
daughter and there were sixty thousand
euros needed to to pay for this
life-saving operation um yeah what what
i did i put a small video on the channel
and asked for for for help at the time
she only had a very difficult to to use
some Georgian bank address to send money
to which yeah I come from from banking I
work in a bank and I know that it's
basically impossible to send money to
such a bank i mean the costs are so high
that you you you basically cannot do it
so we collected money on the channel
sending the donations to to my paypal
account and i forwarded it and i got
them request to update what happened
and I did some text updates in this
video so oh pardon me sorry i did some
text updates from in the in this
original video but let's do a proper
update here um yeah we collected quite a
big amount of money during just two days
and then i can switch here now to the to
facebook page of malia here i'm a friend
on facebook and we see here the timeline
from the start of march where some other
person was posting this request you also
see my little post here just two days
later that we had collected already nine
hundred euros um via the channel it was
simply simply overwhelming to see that
much money collected and right there one
day after that it happened that she also
recognized that this georgian bank
account was very difficult to use so um
there was now starting march seventh um
paypal address to send money directly to
her it was quite irritating at first to
see that there's another name in down
well in Abruzzi keen but okay I was not
so irritated because um this is the wife
of a German Grand Master Mahad predict
in had actually know him from playing
the German championships of our back and
that's the wife and a good friend of
milia so as the money am needed to you
be a used in Germany anyway because
operation was performed in Berlin it was
just logical to get it to a German
address so this was also where I am past
the money on to and at the end of this
nine hundred euros that were collected
by the channel actually got to be eleven
hundred euros because I added something
myself and
some friends from from my chess club
also added something so we were on
eleven hundred euros at the end I can
know I can switch briefly to my paypal
account where you can see just briefly
that there were three payments on those
three days which amount to eleven
hundred euros so this is the only real
proof I can I can give you it's a and
yeah then you can see in the timeline
that a couple of days later somewhere
around here we got the message that the
sixty thousand euros actually had been
raised and here there are a couple of
more cute pictures um that it had been
raised and there were good news some
weeks later middle middle of April that
the operation was indeed a success and
we see a couple of more pictures here
and i must say that i have no idea about
some of the texts here so it's and I
don't know georgian or russian i don't
know i'm sorry i cannot i cannot
translate but what I got to understand
this that her daughter is as well at the
moment but I also understood that this
is a fairly complicated disease and it's
the worst seems to be be over but it's
not like there are no more treatments
necessary so this is why I hadn't posted
something yet because i was hoping to
get some some some news like okay she's
really healthy now but ok there's still
some things to to do obviously so um
this is to wrap up this this yeah great
story and it was great to see them the
gather the amount of help and just just
great to see em what such a small
youtube channel cannon can can
contribute to to a good cause
um what I've added I can also give a
quick update about the town Memorial
which is starting tomorrow 13th of June
and i'll be doing some coverage about
the town memorial probably something
like Game of the day but not quite sure
yet what's what and how much I will do
but i will do some some daily updates
yeah I hope you you like this update and
let's hope that this um yeah the helped
condition of this little child will will
even improve more in the future yeah
thanks for watching and I'll be back
tomorrow with Tom memoria coverage